[Music]
I was 9 years old when I first started
playing organized hockey and it was just
something that came a passion it was a
case where I was playing football in
high school but our games were Saturday
afternoons and I would play football in
the afternoon and then go play hockey at
night because my high school didn't have
a hockey team i started the hockey team
they might see new year also so when I
came to Hillsdale my first year I only
wanted was to get good grades because as
I said my dream was to transfer from
Hillsdale so I could find a school to
play hockey in because I'd been Dean's
List my freshman year I decided well I'm
going to see if I can get a group
together I put up posters around the
campus asking for any students who might
be interested in forming a hockey club
out of the blue we had and I think 10 to
12 skaters some better than the others
that first ragtag team we used to skate
on Bobby's lake or the I'm pond when we
could get some money together we would
go up to the University of Michigan and
usually at midnight at one o'clock was
the only time that we could get the ice
I we'd pile into three or four cars and
drive up there and then skate and that
first year we had four games and then
the last game of the season we drove
down to the Columbus Ohio to play The
Ohio State jayvees and we beat them 17
to nothing so it was a great way to end
our first season and I think the thing
that really brought the success to the
program they built an arena in Jackson
but in 68 69 the last game of the season
was the purdue game and it was standing
room only you couldn't find a place even
to walk his little hillsdale college
playing you know purdue university and
we were losing two to nothing after the
first period and we beat purdue 14 22
when the students went back to campus
there was such a
us about the hockey team that that's
when they put together a petition and
they petitioned the board of trustees to
make it a varsity sport and go to poop I
coach from 1962 to 1963 and when I came
back I coached from nineteen sixty six
to nineteen seventy-four and I never
planned to coach I'd wanted to skate I
wound up coaching and really through
books and other things I had to teach
myself chef caulden left a message on my
phone he said I have to tell you you
know you're being inducted into the
athletic hall of fame it hope they'll
call it he told me that the lot of the
younger players they sent a letter off
to the director of athletics it was
humbling I was very shocked very
surprised but obviously to have it
happen now was just totally amazing and
I'd like that extremely humble
you